set her oh my god that's her that is her  next time on before the ninety days  lard has been constantly texted me table  for two  I want to put that whole situation  behind me alright  I don't know if this relationship is  salvageable but I love her anyway off  I've reached out to Williams I care  about you know Williams a lot and I care  about him telling me the truth mommy's  gonna do the miracle mask I need a  miracle in my life right now ever since  the break-up I've been empowered Taj  obviously loves his dad and the last  thing I want to do is create issues so  filing the k1 visa may not be in our  future I love rose and I don't want our  relationship to end like this so I'm  gonna see if she'll talk to me  nothing in the past even matters  Hey Levens I'm leaving  I don't need your vote I don't need  yours I don't need you  in the deceiving he is  you